you don't take care of your people dude
you ain't you ain't gonna make it in
capitalism this this business suck this
concept of capitalism you're just gonna
sleep at night if you're gonna sit there
spending your money going to gambling
drinking bullshitting not treating your
guys good someone's gonna come and do it
better than you it's that simple right
walmart proved it kmart circuit city
blockbuster you can go on and on and on
with the stories there is nothing that's
the great equalizer than business when
you don't take care of your people so
businesses have that pressure forever
but let me put the opposite side
there's more people that are employees
than there's businesses you also are
creating a reputation you know how i'm
going to put an idea out there if
somebody really did this i think this
would blow up i'm going to put this id
out there
you ready okay we have glassdoor no yeah
so if you want to go right like you can
go to glasgow and check my ratings as a
ceo it's going to say oh this guy's this
guy's and you'll hear some stuff about
me right
you can go check any c on glassdoor
fantastic okay you can go on all these
other places how about we flip it we
create a glasser for employees
every every time you work at a company
you get graded and the employer scores
you when you leave the company on who
you were now there's a glass there for
the employee so millions of people in
america now have a score for how good of
an employee you want
a social credit exactly no no i'm sorry
but if but wait a minute if the big guys
have the pressure and they got that
magnifying glass under why shouldn't
everybody else i agree with you so yeah
isn't that what a resume is they check
no it's not no it's not are you kidding
me like you know when people i do
interviews and they'll i'll say so hey
there's a year and a half gap here what
happened my mom was sick i i was you
know i was taking care of my mom there
you know it's just a very emotional
tough time for us like wow i'm so what
are you asking that moment
do you sit there and you say i see a
proof of your mom
can i show you his medical record and
the mom is 48 years old dude your mom's
a fitness model yeah yeah yeah but the
point is this is the stuff that you
don't see so if we really want to go
there i'm totally cool with it man let's
just put your score online let's see how
good of an employee you are and then
maybe we realized this guy's been fired
nine times in five years okay no we
ain't hiring you or change because the
market's overpaying you and you suck
flat your former employee starts suing
you yeah yeah the former employee starts
suing you yeah because you're giving
them bad ratings i i think i think if
there is i think if this was an open
thing that we all did and there's
accountability on both sides let's go at
it it's very simple let's go at it so i
think that there's a lot of people that
would be super into that i think so too
and i think maybe it's a business model
we ought to consider who knows maybe
we'll do it anybody else doesn't go
through it i'm going to say one thing
about this yeah
where you could like rate your exes or
something like that and it was like
i'm sure there's not a lot of vindictive
or anything like that yeah i forget what
it was called oh my god only women only
women could date men we could rape like
dudes and then like but the problem with
it was was like you didn't make your own
uh
oh man what the what was the name of
this you didn't make your own profile
somebody made a profile for you and then
like if you were a player they sent it
around and the next thing you know it
was like it was called like pickle or
something like that what the heck
what was the name of this thing man bad
dating guy yeah dude hey are you on
pickle
no
yeah man it was i think i think it's x's
ratio i'm sure that's not going to be
yeah we're not going to make it
well that's the same thing with ex
bosses all things end poorly or else
they want to know
i'll give you an idea if you hired me at
16 years old this was my resume you
ready there you go you shouldn't have
hired me x-rated lets you review your ex
from hygiene to mojo to all the world to
see huh
okay it's called x-rated is what it's
called i don't know where i got 2011
yeah is a lot better name than uh pickle
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]
you